eighty years ago we thought that the
entire universe consists of what we know
today as our Milky Way galaxy which made
sense at the time our our Milky Way
galaxy is a huge place our Milky Way
galaxy has a diameter of 100,000
light-years so if you shined a
flashlight from one end of the Milky Way
traveling at 186,000 miles per second it
still takes 100,000 years for that
flashlight beam to finally reach the
other side of our Milky Way galaxy
being so big it's not surprising we
thought our Milky Way was the universe
but we now know that it's only one of
about 100 billion other galaxies in the
cosmos so many galaxies in fact that if
they suddenly turned into peas they fill
a Sports Arena
and in each of these galaxies there are
tens even hundreds of billions of stars
all together it adds up to a universe
with more stars than most of us can
imagine how fast is space for an example
that might make sense come to the beach
think of the grains of sand and every
handful I pick up I've got more than 8
million grains of sand
and all the planet we think there one
quadrillion grains of sand
but there's still nothing compared to
space we know now that there are about
200 billion galaxies in each galaxy it's
home to 200 billion stars so it really
is true the space is more vast with more
stars than there are grains of sand on
all the beaches of planet Earth
that's amazing